four super bowl championships along with
joe montana they got leap frog by
tom brady aaron rodgers still has three
to go to catch them
brad shaw was on wfan the moose and
maggie show
yesterday and had some things to say
about aaron rodgers let's have a listen
to the original tb12
with him being that upset shows me just
how weak he is
who the hell cares who you draft
i mean i never there's a three-time mvp
in the league and he's worried about
this guy they drafted
last year at number one and for him to
be upset
my god i don't understand that
pittsburgh drafted
mark malone number one cliff stout in
the third or fourth round i had
i had him coming at me from all angles
uh
i embraced it because when we went to
practice
i wasn't worried about those guys you
know it didn't scare me a bit
so i don't understand
why he's so upset
at green bay and then then if they fire
the general manager he'll come back are
you kidding me
really aaron that's that's where this is
here's what i'd do
i wouldn't budge let him gripe let him
cry
retire you're 38 go ahead and retire see
you later i mean
i'm really strong about stuff like that
and it just makes him look weak in my
way of looking it makes him look weak
do you think the threat is an empty one
of retirement from rogers
hadn't thought of it like that
i i love how you just get exactly what
you see
oh just raw raw emoji like he's like you
know i've really never thought of it
never so
let me think about it right here hold on
and then and then he went back and forth
he went back and forth on it four or
five times
and he said i've never been this
wishy-washy on anything in my life
but i think he eventually if i recall
correctly and who the hell knows because
he was back and forth on it so many
times i think he eventually said
he's bluffing call his bluff right and
and that's the old school football
mindset
right call is bluff that's what we think
the packers are gonna do
at least for now call is bluff so
i i think terry probably was already on
the list of guys aaron rodgers doesn't
like
if he wasn't he's the latest name to be
added to it
yeah right calling him out the way that
he did he just put his name above yours
that's what he did he was like wait
florio at the top of the list hold on i
got one little space here bradshaw on
top
now um well i i said to somebody
yesterday
that that i've been on the list for so
long the page my name is on is more
cracked and yellow than cramer's teeth
when he started smoking oh well don't
that's how long i've been on the line
don't worry
he gets a fresh piece of paper and a
nice new marker every now and then
he's laminated like his vaccination gets
it up there he ain't gonna forget
don't you worry uh but you know listen
it is it is difficult to watch with
rogers
it is i think very strange for the old
school
player and even fan to get their head
wrapped around like the current state of
athletics the way stars are
aaron rodgers whatever it may be you
know there's all issues there
you know first off what i would want to
say to terry bradshaw just go
it's not about he cares about the
quarterback he's not worried about that
it's just about
he wants the team to uh
commit to him he doesn't want to go on
he doesn't want to be in a one-year
wait are they going to keep me or they
not going to keep me thing it's not
about jordan love
or anything like that so that's what i
would say to that and you know he brings
up like the point about
hey they drafted quarterbacks and things
like that well yes
they drafted quarterbacks and you
embraced it one you've already won four
super bowls
at that point so you're the king of
pittsburgh we know that
there's no threat to you and two you're
cut
he was coming to the end of his career
like it wasn't mvp
level stipe ty style or type of football
anymore
that's where it's a little different too
with rogers and everything like that
so that's where i would just go and then
hey i mean terry brown
they didn't draft dan marino in 1983
because they still had terry bradshaw
exactly and like terry bradshaw he threw
eight more passes
eight exactly so it was coming to an end
and like everybody knew it to a degree
the other thing too is just like
i mean bradshaw's been very sensitive
that's the only thing that bothered me a
little bit yesterday where i want to go
wait this is the guy who didn't go back
to pittsburgh for 30 years
because of because what i don't they
didn't let him retire on his own terms
right
i mean isn't that basically what it was
about he felt like
he didn't get to do it his way
rogers not a grudge rogers wants to do
it his way
i mean so that's where i just don't like
the the the
bradshaw take he's a guy i really love
it i love listening to but
i didn't totally agree with everything
he said there but i will say this when
they did use a first-round pick on
quarterback mark malone now the times
were different
that's another thing internet that's
right there was no sports talk radio
it wasn't a big eruption as far as
anyone knew
right and maybe he just kept his mouth
shut until he got to one training camp
and realized this guy stinks
there's nothing for me to be worried
about yeah no i respect him
right well i think that's i i i have a
feeling and i've heard that's kind of
like aaron rodgers thought
up in green bay was like this guy's raw
he's nowhere near ready
i'm not worried i think he realized that
real early last year i heard that from
people up there
so you know i don't think that's it and
yeah you know with bradshaw come on
early on in his career man he hated
chuck noll
he wanted to kind of get the hell out of
there he was he was miserable
so that's where i just don't like like
come on let's not be hypocritical now
because there's somebody doing it and
to your point mike come on the world is
different
it's different for these athletes social
media has upped the ante in a big way
you know like you said back in those
days hey there was
three tv stations and a radio station
that's all everybody listened to
now you go on your phone and you look at
something
and you could find 90 million things of
like rogers is a choke artist rogers is
not the greatest all like
he's pinned to a label forever in this
generation
and all these athletes are and that's
why they've taken power into their own
hands because they're going to go
wait i'm done with like hoping my gm
and i can get lucky that my team will
set me up they're they're being held to
a standard so they're going nope i'll be
my own gm
i'm going to get my own place if you're
going to if they're going to compare
legacies and do all this
well not everybody gets to be like magic
johnson on the lakers that has kareem
abdul-jabbar and all these other good
players and then you get fortunate to
win all those games and
other great athletes who have had that
so athletes are trying to make their own
moves now that's a different
generation it's not apples to apples is
what i'm saying it's not fair to compare
it
if social media existed in the early 70s
terry bradshaw would have been doing two
shows a night
guitar in hand singing country music
telling jokes saying things that he
shouldn't be saying publicly about the
football team
and it would have been the most
entertaining thing going he just feels
like
he just was born at the wrong time or at
the right time as the case may be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports